In this last video, you add the final touches to the scene by importing the missing elements. These include people, cars, and some additional props.
Import the last Datasmith file, the one named Props, as you have learned before.
There will be some issues with the import that you can check in the message log.
These mostly relate to animated people and animated cars that do not translate well between Twinmotion and Unreal Engine.
Delete the redundant background and get closer to the scene.
Note that any posed characters imported correctly, but that any animated characters did not.
That's the import restriction as it currently stands.
Anything else that is static, like furniture and decorations, imported flawlessly.
Interestingly, all vehicles did import, but they are static. Their animations didn't come through.
Again, this is a known restriction that we currently have.
However, note the green squares in front and behind each car. These are decal objects for the headlights and taillights.
Unfortunately, their material did not translate correctly between Twinmotion and Unreal Engine, so we'll need to fix that.
Create a new folder under Content Theatron, Props, Materials, and name it Decals.
Create a new material named MCarLights.
Set the new material to be used as a deferred decal and set the blend mode to Translucent.
Look in the Textures folder and note the two imported textures TLightMaskFrontBC and TLightMaskRearBC.
These represent the front and taillights on the cars.
Drag the TLightMaskFrontBC texture into the newly created material.
Convert the node to a parameter and call it Light Mask.
This will allow you to change it at the instance level.
You could wire it directly to the emissive channel, but let's give ourselves a bit more control.
Press 3 and click in the material editor to add a color node.
Again, make it a parameter and name it Tint.
You'll use this to tint the mask which will be useful for the taillights.
Make the default color white though.
Press M and click to add a Multiply node.
Multiply the two nodes and then add another Multiply node before you wire that to the emissive channel.
The second Multiply node will be useful to control the intensity of the effect.
Add a Scalar node, S on the keyboard, and name it Intensity.
Wire it to the second Multiply node and set its default value to 1.
Save the material and close the material editor.
Create two material instances named miHeadlights and miTaillights.
Adjust their parameters such as intensities and colors.
You may need to revisit these values again.
Also make sure the taillights are based on the appropriate mask image.
Use the Outline Research Box to filter all the Decal F actors in the scene.
Note that the Twinmotion material assignment didn't carry through.
Assign the miHeadlights material you just created.
And repeat the procedure for the taillights or Decal R.
Switch to Nighttime to view the effects.
Lastly, you can help the night scene by adding a bit of a moon effect.
Add a Directional Light to the scene.
It will conflict with the SunSky system.
Rename the actor Moonlight and move it to the Lighting folder.
Note the error in the viewport. You need to adjust the Forward Shading Priority value.
Search for it in the Details panel and set it to 1 to remove the conflict.
Look also for Atmosphere and set the Sunlight Index to 1.
This will bring the sky and clouds into effect.
Change the light color to a blue that you like and reduce the intensity.
This will make the environment a bit more visible at night instead of being drowned in darkness.
It will not affect the scene much in daytime.
Save your project now that you have transferred your Twinmotion scene into UE5.
This brings us to the end of this class. I hope you have found it useful.